eu não sou arquiteto de informação
muitas pessoas falam trabalha com
moradia e tudo mais mas eu não sou
arquiteto não me formei nessa área
mas apesar disso ou eu venho me
envolvendo muito ativamente com a
temática da habitação nos últimos anos
de habitação é um tema muito
interessante né porque junto com
alimentação com a vestimenta
talvez a casa represente as nossas
necessidades básicas mais primitivas e
mas apesar disso há o que eu tenho
encantado ultimamente é o quanto a casa
é mais do que essa necessidade básica
primitiva o quanto ela é mais que a
questão do abrigo da segurança física eu
tenho encantado como a casa tem uma
função psicológica extremamente
importante de abrigo e segurança
psicológico mesmo enquanto que a casa
pode ser uma plataforma para o
desenvolvimento humano se kiko e de
transformação social é um pouco sobre
isso que eu queria eu quero conversar
com vocês hoje
apesar de não ter feito faculdade não
ser da área da arquitetura da habitação
envolve em 2009 mais ou menos num
contexto de um programa de urbanização
de favelas em são paulo uma favela na
zona leste de são paulo
a minha ação o projeto em si no qual
estava envolvido não tinha nada a ver
com a habitação é a provocação foi feita
pra gente era olha essa favela aqui que
acabou de passar por um processo de
urbanização ea gente quer preparar a
comunidade para receber esses espaços
novos essas praças novas etc
então a idéia é que as ações gerem
apropriação pelo bairro novo e a gente
juntou nossos melhores homens para fazer
uma tarefa que é uma encrenca como essa
mas a gente tinha muita dificuldade
isso na verdade porque as praças barra
às escolas as praças as ruas
efetivamente estavam bonitas mas a gente
começou a perceber que as casas das
pessoas eram estruturados e era muito
difícil para as pessoas
partida essa desestruturação parte desse
acolhimento do seu próprio espaço e
pedir pra elas acolher em outro espaço
ainda externo e no que não estava ali e
isso gerou uma série de entendimentos e
aprendizados
o primeiro deles é o que não era da
nunca tinha visto uma urbanização de
favela entendido e tinha minhas imagens
do que era um processo de urbanização de
favela o primeiro choque que eu tive é
que um processo de urbanização de favela
que é um uma iniciativa com um
investimento gigantesco esse projeto
especial era o maior programa de
urbanização de favelas do estado de são
paulo que eventualmente o estado mais
rico do país é um caminhão de dinheiro
sendo investido ali para melhorar as
ruas e tudo mais só que todas as ações é
e todo o recurso é injetado no que chama
de da porta pra fora das casas que é o
saneamento é a praça a escola agora da
porta para dentro das casas
a condição continuava a mesma as casas
continuavam insalubres com humildade e
sem ventilação com banheiro adequado e
claro que em um processo de urbanização
remove-se algumas casas mas a grande
maioria delas continua lá
ou seja é o problema doméstico das
pessoas não é resolvido e além disso
outra coisa que ficou evidente para mim
conhecendo o que que é o contexto
habitacional e um programa de
urbanização e essa experiência me
mostrou é que boa parte do foco das
ações de habitação no país
elas são focadas na construção de novas
moradias
então hoje olhando pro brasil a gente
tem um déficit habitacional de 6 milhões
de moradias
precisamos construir 6 milhões de novas
casas para a gente dar conta do problema
só que a gente tem um outro problema que
é duas vezes maior que o chama de
déficit qualitativo que são as casas já
existentes porém inadequadas 12 milhões
de moradias
e se a gente pegar os principais
programas públicos como minha casa minha
vida por exemplo que é fantástico
de forma alguma quero diminuir o
programa ele está focado em construção
não é apenas a gente pegar as principais
ações da iniciativa privada também
relacionado com as ações de governo
foco em construção se a gente pegar boa
parte das organizações sociais que
trabalham com habitação os movimentos de
moradia etc
o foco é construção e o problema que
duas vezes maior é praticamente não
interessado por ninguém
então essa experiência no contexto da
urbanização daquela favela que a gente
trabalhava começou a me fazer cair umas
fichas de que existe uma lacuna imensa
existe uma lacuna imensa no brasil que
são essas 2 milhões de moradias que são
esses cerca de 40 milhões de brasileiros
que já tem uma casa mas que vive em
condições completamente inadequadas e
que não contam com acesso pra passar
desse ponto para apurar essa fase é para
melhorar de vida
então quando esse projeto acabou e dois
amigos que trabalhávamos nessa
iniciativa a gente ficou com essa pulga
atrás da orelha foi o parece que tem uma
lacuna aqui que não tem gente
interessando e se não tem eventualmente
a gente pode se meter a besta de de
entrar nessa né
então a gente é bom mas já estávamos
lendo yunus né quando caio livre do
yunus na nossa mão e na mão de qualquer
um aquilo ali não deixa ninguém pais
nessa encrenca dos livros do rio nas
eleições fala curta agora tem que fazer
alguma coisa e depois que a gente acabou
de lei que ficou com esse sentimento é
que agora não vai dar pra gente não
fazer nada ele falou bom vamos só que
como a gente vai fazer né eu
particularmente nunca
tinha feito obra reforma e etc mas a
gente tinha convicção de que a gente só
ia conseguir construir alguma coisa
junto com as pessoas que vivem o
problema
então a gente fez uma parceria com uma
ong que a gente conhecia que ficava numa
outra favela na zona sul de são paulo
do outro lado da cidade e chegamos pra
eles falam olha a nossa ideia é essa a
gente viu esse problema a gente entende
que a questão de reformas de melhoria
habitacional não é endereçada da melhor
forma possível ea gente queria conversar
com quem vive esse problema com quem
resolver essa situação para ver se dá
pra construir uma solução
e aí o pessoal foi ótimo vamos juntar um
grupo de moradores que for mais gente
faz esse grupo de discussão
ficamos seis meses ouvindo essas pessoas
e logo de cara né no primeiro dia é a
gente teve a felicidade é de compreender
o que talvez seja o mantra da reforma
dizem que a reforma você não termina
você desiste
eu tô vendo um monte de gente com a
cabeça assim né de muita gente que
reformou por aí né
e aí comecei a entender como é que é
esse processo de reforma lá né no
contexto da favela e apesar da
reformulação da encrenca para todo mundo
lá é pior claro envolvido em todo esses
custos extras da pobreza e à reforma que
qualquer outra pessoa que tenha crédito
ou esteja em outra condição econômica
como foi mostrado aqui faz reforma é
pega um crédito com os materiais
contrato de entrega o que a gente viu
dos moradores lá eram diferente então
este mês sobre um pouquinho de dinheiro
vai na loja de material de construção
compra 12 aquecimento
a stock aí passa um mês trabalhando mais
um pouco sobre mais um pouquinho compra
mais um saco de cimento
só que aquele primeiro já choveu em cima
já molhou já perdeu né e aí tem que
comprar de novo a repor a que do ponto
de vista de construção é ou você vai
encontrar
há algum pedreiro local só que o bom
pedreiro da favela trabalhando para as
grandes construtoras né
o que sobra para o cara é aquele que faz
tudo que não faz nada direito né então a
obra fica com uma qualidade péssima
a outra opção é fazer o esquema do fim
de semana se chama os amigos falam vamos
lá a gente toma uma cerveja faz uma
coisa né e vai trabalhando uma cerveja
faz uma primeira fiada de tijolo aqui tá
ótimo toma segunda cerveja faz o segundo
na quarta quinta cerveja a parede está
assim né então do ponto de vista de
qualidade não é uma boa opção também o
que a gente começou a ver é que a
reforma que era feita uma reforma muito
ineficiente e o que eles contaram pra
gente é que eram quatro os principais
problemas para se fazer reforma na
favela que são esse não é o primeiro
acesso a crédito
as favelas tendem a estar localizadas em
áreas não regularizadas ou seja você não
tem a matrícula do imóvel não imóvel
formal e banco para financiar a reforma
construção qualquer coisa precisa ter
como garantia aquela matrícula ou seja
nesse contexto sem chance
a segunda é que eu não sei se dá pra ler
aí a assessoria técnica quer dizer todos
os profissionais de arquitetura e da
área de habitação é que oferecem
serviços que estudam e oferecem serviços
pra ajudar nós cidadãos comuns a
construir reformar não são voltados para
esse público
ou você tem um escritório de arquitetura
tradicional que só trabalha com quem é
mais rico ou você tenha songs as
organizações de apoio técnico
só que de novo são braços técnicos dos
movimentos de moradia que focam
construção do ponto de vista de reforma
praticamente não tem né
e assim pra tudo né a gente viu esse
cenário depois desses nesse processo de
seis meses de escutar a história e
quando acabou sendo bom vamos ver o que
existe no mercado para ver se dá pra
fazer a ponte
nessa gente consegue fazer um link para
fazer uma reforma mais eficiente e então
fomos aos bancos e contamos olha vamos
bancos desde os grandes bancos
comerciais brasileiros
até os pequenos micro crédito mas e aí
vamos aos bancos apresentamos todos e
ele fala olha chegamos a ouvir um banco
seguinte falta literatura para a gente
fazer crédito para reforma
nisso né foi bom eu vou apresentar meus
amigos escritores de livros aqui quem
sabe de repente gente evento uma nova
moda né e um cenário de não né isso se
repetiu tudo é que ele chegou à
conclusão de que ou a gente não fazer
nada por conta desses não todos
a gente ia ter que fazer alguma coisa né
e se alguma coisa tem que envolver tudo
a gente já tem que ser banco a gente tem
que ser arquiteto a gente já tem que ter
mão de obra qualificada a gente tinha
que providenciar o material a gente vai
ter que entregar tudo no meio desse
processo desses seis meses de escuta
acontecer um evento que foi muito triste
e muito simbólico para a gente a dormir
deu se com essa moça ela era uma das
integrantes desse grupo e ela fugir até
um pouco do perfil ela era contratada
formal de uma empresa multinacional
trabalhava com limpeza la a ter
registrado o dinheiro na conta e tudo
mais que iria reformar precisava de uma
ajuda e foi no segundo semestre essa
conversa foi de junho a dezembro em
novembro deus e morreu
isso foi um baita de um choque pra gente
porque é uma pessoa muito próxima a
gente fazer as reuniões na frente da
casa dela ea dona dulce morreu
os sucessivos ciclos de pneumonia ela
tinha o médico dela já tinha falado pra
ela mudou-se aqui nessa casa da senhora
mora não tem uma janela
as paredes são totalmente mofadas a
senhora não vai curar uma pneumonia ou
senhora muda ou de algum problema jeito
ou não vai curar não curou é e morreu
e essa história do deus se fez a gente
perceber que a habitação não é uma
questão só de habitação de moradia é uma
questão de saúde pública
as casas estão matando indiretamente
quando a gente viu que era isso foi bom
com a reforma que a gente vai fazer é
tem que entender essa saúde a gente
acabou de descobrir que o problema aqui
a saúde não é a habitação inteligência a
gente foi buscar literatura de saúde e
habitação têm muito pouco ea gente viu
um pouco dessa literatura médica que
foca habitação que as principais
patologias habitacionais que mais
impactam a saúde dos moradores são
quatro que são é banheiro excesso de
umidade ventilação e revestimento
quando a gente viu isso então já temos
que a gente vai fazer a gente vai fazer
o kit banheiro que intimidade que teve
em relação à crítica investimento para
endereçar diretamente à causa
nesse ponto a gente já tinha produtos e
tinha um modelo que é esse modelo de
entregar tudo junto né o crédito
assistência técnica e tudo mais
com isso a gente na parte de crédito a
gente começou a operar com dois modelos
um modelo que é de forma subsidiada e
que as famílias mais vulneráveis que
ganhou renda familiar mensal de até um
salário mínimo e meio
tem um subsídio e re pagam só 30% do
valor da obra e outro modelo é um
morador e paga 100% do valor da obra em
15 vezes em parcelas que cabem no bolso
neste um ano de operação primeiro da do
programa venda a gente fez 104 obras foi
nosso grande teste de produto
assim é obras banheiros como esse que
depois ficaram assim cozinhas como essa
que depois ficaram assim e quarto
gum
quartos como esse
com toda essa unidade e depois ficaram
assim e a gente teve uma série de
experiências nesse primeiro ano a ideia
é a gente inaugura agora uma segunda
fase em que a gente quer testar outras
coisas uma vez que o produto já já
tivemos bastante experiência testar o
modelo de venda e assim que estiver
pronta a terceira fase é escalar isso
para o país todo tem um escritório do
programa vem em cada favela pra gente
expandir o trabalho feito mas há talvez
uma das maiores experiências que a gente
teve aconteceu logo na primeira obra que
foi um banheiro é o banheiro da aeronave
era muito ruim é um banheiro que tinha
chão de terra ainda assim não tinha um
sistema de saneamento ligado na rede e
tudo mais
a água que escorria fazer um buraco
tinha bicho minhoca é é um pouco ruim
mesmo banheiro dela e ela falava pra
gente uma das histórias que acontecem
muito do tipo olha nunca fiz uma festa
de aniversário do meu filho aqui em casa
porque eu tinha vergonha de convidar os
amigos dele porque não tinha banheiro
com as pessoas fazer xixi então a gente
começou a ver a os impactos né indiretos
de um banheiro adequado na vida no
desenvolvimento das pessoas mas o
goleiro daniel ficou lindo ficou um
brinco com o melhor do meu neto todo
mundo que veio falar poxa esse banheiro
era o que a gente caprichou também pra
né ficar uma perna e quando a gente
chegou a reforma terminou um dia no dia
seguinte a gente foi na casa de ana logo
de manhã para saber como tinha sido a
primeira noite um banheiro novo todo
bonitão então
e quando a gente chegou lá na falou isso
mas se gerar um problema pra mim que se
imagina né
aí foi bom que foi na de algum problema
técnico tal a falar não
a história é a seguinte antes os meus
filhos tinham era um medo de no banheiro
ficava escuro tinha bicho tudo mais é
uma baita briga pra fazer lá e nem o
ontem foi uma baita briga para tirar os
meninos né
gina o quanto eu vou pagar de conta de
água agora depois desse banho mas o que
foi mais interessante disso tudo não foi
isso é e sim que quando a gente estava
chegando na casa de ana para fazer essa
visita ana estava varrendo a rua a viela
na frente da casa dela
a gente nunca tinha visto a nova regra
havia nem vieram em favela tende a ser
uma coisa um pouco suja tem muito cocô
de cachorro né não é um e quando a gente
viu aquilo a gente toma um susto
ante um para o outro assim acontecendo
perguntou o que está acontecendo na vila
o que está acontecendo pra isso a gente
viu que estava reyna vieram mas a gente
nunca viu silva revela que aconteceu a
falar há agora que estou com meu
banheiro limpinho vou deixar alguém
pisar aqui na rua e sujar meu banheiro
né
isso pra gente foi uma coisa porque a
gente lembrou do projeto lá da
urbanização da favela em que a gente
tinha que pensar em uma série de
estratégias para fazer as pessoas se
apropriarem do espaço público e ao
contrário do que aconteceu aí foi um
processo natural orgânico não é não era
o que a gente imaginava que a gente viu
o quão transformador uma reforma
habitacional é na vida da pessoa e eo
quanto que uma reforma a reforma não só
a casa mas toda a cadeia de
relacionamento que tem ali da casa da
pessoa com a casa da pessoa consigo
mesmo da pessoa contorno cozinho com a
viela reformar uma casa mudar uma vida é
mudar uma comunidade limite e ficou
muito evidente pra gente que tanto no
nosso nível individual quanto no âmbito
comunitário trabalho de desenvolvimento
comunitário que a reforma de verdade a
mudança de verdade não vem de fora ela
sempre vem de dentro
obrigado